thanks hi everyone um welcome to my talk
on yeah observability for distributed
computing online and in particular with
dasc um
as introduced I'm Henrik Makai I work as
an open source software engineer at
called where I mainly work on desk and
it's a suited runtime engine
um so before we dive into observability
let's first quickly talk about Das and
how it relates to distributed computing
task is a library for general purpose
parallelism in Python which means that
it can help you paralyze pretty much
all workloads or all kinds of workloads
that you want to run as an easiest
example you can parallelize something
like this where you just have a bunch of
files you want to iterate over those and
just process them embarrassing in
parallel without any interactions Dallas
can do that
does it also has some pretty nice
Integrations into the existing Pi data
ecosystem so if you have data frame
based workloads running on numpy running
on pandas sorry or you have area
computations in numpy dusk has paralyzed
versions of those that help you to
paralyze your code without having to
rewrite everything and having to learn a
different API
just use what you have in place and use
a small drop in
but since its general purpose dusk also
allows you to bring your custom
workloads however complex or dynamic
they may be
um
for that we have low level apis that you
can use and the graph can look as
complicated as something like this and
it will still be able to get paralyzed
now
task is not only a library for
parallelization but it also comes with a
dissuited runtime with a distributed
execution engine that means that you can
now take whatever you paralyze and not
only run it on all eight cores on your
machines but you can actually paralyze
it and scale it to hundreds or even
thousands of machines and therefore also
run it on much larger data sizes
there are several deployments options
for this so if you have a kubernetes
cluster you can use that
HPC clusters
also the cloud work so if you want to
run it on your AWS or gcp setup
their deployment options for this or you
can just use a managed service like task
which takes care of the deployment
planes for you
um
now let's make this a little practical
to understand things
and for this I have one question
who are likes breaking things
you guys
yes you all are why we can't have nice
things but I also like breaking things I
really don't like if you just have a
glossy demo so what I've prepared here
is just something where we totally will
break dusk
I've already spun up cluster here with
20 workers and we're just going to run
this small workload here where we're
going to read a ton of data from parquet
aggregated try to calculate a bunch of
medians from it and
yeah then just get it small result this
should all fit into memory everything
should be great
and we see the cluster picked up the
work
then we have the Das dashboards here we
can see the progress being made we can
see that there's a bunch of tasks
running we see how much data we store in
the cluster we can also see CPU usage
and yes slowly but it's making its way
forward
um
we can also see stuff like
workers what they're up to
we have system information we have some
metrics here you see pretty much what
the cluster does
we can also go into code where I've now
spawned up a cluster once again we have
some stuff we can see
there's some code we see what code we
run what we execute we have even more
metrics
we see logs logs are useful
um
and then eventually we even have more
complicated stuff more rich
visualizations like grafana here
that's all great our workload is doing
stuff
that's what it's supposed to do and oh
no things failed I broke dusk that's
kind of what I wanted to do in the end
um
the runtime error here is yeah kind of
tells me what happened the shuffle broke
but um
why
if only we had a cluster if only we had
a system that could tell us what
happened and why it happened
and in other words
well if only we had observability
so what is observability is to get
everybody on the same page here I quite
like this definition from the open
Telemetry project
and that says that observability lets us
understand the system from the outside
without really knowing what's going on
inside
it allows us to ask questions about the
system handle novel problems even the
ones that we didn't anticipate before
and where we didn't set up an alert
before
and most importantly it allows us to ask
the question of like why did something
happen not just what happened
so in essence observability is a
property of a system that allows us to
take all sorts of actions like
monitoring root causing issues debugging
them or even just like analyzing
performance and optimizing Hardware
utilization
how do we get to an observable system
for this is usually these three
beautiful pillars of observability being
cited those are logs metrics and tracing
those are the kinds of telemetry data
you want to add to your system to be
able to understand it
and in this talk I'm actually going to
skip tracing because that's pretty much
a talk on its own uh not enough time for
this unfortunately but instead I want to
talk about diagnostic tooling because
it's all nice if you have Telemetry
somewhere in your system but how do you
actually interact with that how can
users see that data make sense of it how
can they ask questions about the system
and answer them
now first let's talk a little bit about
logging
all of us no locks I guess it's this
beautiful wall of text scrolling by on
some screen when you tell the output of
a program a program you run can be
overwhelming at times
and before we dive into the interesting
bits here let's quickly recap logging
best practices that you should all
follow first one don't use print
is bad like just don't use it if you
don't know why take a look at the
documentation of one of the logging
libraries but there's a lot of things
you will learn from that and there's a
lot of functionality you're missing out
if you're just relying on print to get
something into your standard out
next thing is provide necessary context
we just said that we want to understand
why things happen in your system not
just what happened so give me context
for that if for example in a dance class
and you're stopping at work I don't say
like I stop at work or now tell me which
worker did you start maybe even why did
you do that in the first place
I want to know what happened and in
which context
last but not least if you want to really
take it to the next level and want to go
into some Advanced levels of lock usage
use structured logs this will help you
to
on the one hand have still human
readable locks but also be able to
process them in some systems analyze
them with machines without having to
write annoying regex
now
most of you probably know this you might
be asking so yeah cool now I follow
these best practices for logging um am I
done now
well
if you're using a single machine setup
if you're just running a bonding
application on one server you're
probably good at this point but
let's consider this
you now scale to cluster of 100 workers
what happens
well congratulations we now have 102
places where we can look for our
beautiful locks
I don't know how you feel about as it's
aging into 102 workers figuring out what
the logs are reading through files
figuring out what's going on
um I don't like that
so there's better ways to do this
one way is already built into desk and
that is that you can ask the client for
example to get to you some of the
scheduler logs
you can also ask you to get the the
worker logs or even just specific worker
logs if you know that already something
happened just on this particular machine
the problem with that is that this works
as long as things are live and as long
as they'll answer your questions
but since we're usually looking and
looking into logs when we're debugging
stuff chances are pretty high that
worker is long dead because something
bad happened to it and if it's dead it
doesn't answer your messages it doesn't
return locks
instead what you want to do in desk and
pretty much any distributed system is
you want to centralize your logging in
an external system
so that means you take all the logs from
all the machines you have from all the
programs you have to ship them over into
some other system that takes care of
first of all storing all of those logs
and then letting you query those
with that in place you can retroactively
analyze what happened on your systems
even if your cluster is long gone
you'll know what happens when a worker
died because it still might have sent
over last couple of logs that were
informative
and if you followed for example
structured log invest practices you have
Rich functionality to query those logs
as well
this is like an easy example of just
querying some stuff with the called
cluster API we're just asking for logs
from a specific user because memory
usage looked odd and we just want to see
hey what's going on on that one
let's now actually take a look at logs
for our example to understand how useful
and maybe also how annoying logs are
what we'll see here is there are a lot
of logs
on the one hand this is great
because
yes when we have locks we can really
dive into problems we can really dig
down into what happened understand where
things failed
and this really has some rich
information in there
the downside is
um if I don't know where to start
how will I figure that out
instead what I want to have is something
that gives us a bit of a glimpse into
what happens in your system by just
looking at it briefly and not reading
through blocks from 20 workers for half
an hour
that's where metrics come in that's the
next point I want to talk about
metrics are all these beautiful things
all those measurements you collect about
your system at runtime that we usually
use in some visualizations in grafana
dashboards and other things
to take a look see roughly what happened
in our cluster and then be able to
hopefully drill down into this
in dasc we have a bunch of metrics
exposed
this is to give you as users the
opportunity like yeah get some detailed
information statistic about what's
happening inside the system and its
components
Um this can go from like relatively easy
stuff like how many workers does the
schedule actually know about to more
detailed metrics like the memory
breakdown per worker how much of it is
managed memory how much memory have we
spilled um how does that differ between
workers is there some imbalancer Maybe
and there's many others like we won't go
into details about this
if you're interested take a look at the
documentation that we have
now similar to logging
you also want to have centralized
metrics once again we want to have this
stuff available for a long time even
when the cluster is dead
for this task has a native Prometheus
integration
and that allows Prometheus which is a
metrics time series database and pretty
much any compatible system to just
continuously ask the cluster for metrics
about it and we can use that in a
centralized system to uh get a picture
of what's going on and even track that
over time
if we have those centralized metrics we
can do pretty powerful stuff with that
we can on the one hand have those
beautiful and Powerful dashboards here
like this one which is from the class of
that just died we
if we scroll through this here we can
see that there's a lot of information
that we've collected
and maybe we can also use this to figure
out why our cluster died why our Shuffle
failed
um
this a lot of stuff going on here but
there's one thing in particular that
looks interesting and this is it like
here we have disk usage and
suddenly disk usage went to a hundred
percent and died
um we all know 100 disk users is usually
pretty bad
things fail when that happens because we
can't write to disk anymore so let's
maybe see if that was the cause of our
problems here
see maybe there's something usually
there's something like space left
complained by by python and if we take a
look at the locks here once again
there's a lot of them we see yes indeed
at some point during the shuffle we did
not have any space left on the machine
and that's why everything failed when
things died why things broke down and
why that's just blew up exploded
so yeah
this is how metrics helped us solve this
case
but
um
not only that we can also just have
things that proactively or retroactively
tell us if something is off like we can
have alerts most of us know this we
should probably have an alert that like
if this users goes to 90 95 things are
bad we should probably take a look at
this or we could also tell users that
what we do in college here for example
things looked up and they should
probably take a look at this in the end
like
the cluster I used yes it used memory
and did used disk in particular
we knew this was a problem here so it's
good that we alert us
um we see that there's Network traffic
that's kind of useful because it's a
distributed system but also we want to
minimize that external network traffic
even worse because it's slower
so we can use metrics to
also make sure that users or
developers just use a system in a good
way and make sure that it's uh
performant
now
let's also take a look at another
example of how we used
metrics to make decisions at call for
users
and this is was something where we tried
to figure out which workers which AWS
instance types should we use as a
default for customers
in particular we compared two things
those are T3 large instances m6i large
instances those are in terms of CPU and
memory pretty much the same
um
one of them is cheaper the other one is
not but let's see how they compare in
different workloads um
and what we see here is that T3 large if
you have something that uses a lot of
network and disk
is actually pretty bad it takes a lot
longer and if you trust me on this one
this number here the throughput we
achieved for the m6is is much higher
than for the t3s so if you just take a
look at that yeah T3 is lose out
if we take a look at another workload
where you just use more CPU or less
constrained by the i o that we can
achieve once again we see still T3 large
takes a lot longer
and we have this weird steel thing going
on so we're not exactly using CPU
efficiently
and by comparing those kinds of
workloads and then digging a bit through
the documentation we were able to figure
out that
first of all
yes
those T3 large instances are worse for
data science and data engineering
workloads because they have worse
Hardware when it comes to to IO
um and also
they're cheaper but if you use a lot of
CPU they actually become more expensive
and also if you lose 10 minutes more of
CPU those
per minute uh savings you had don't
really come into play
so in our case we ended up actually
shifting default instance types to m6is
because they're much better for these
data science data engineering workloads
that we use
um
and we were able basically to achieve
this through metrics and understand
what's going on why things are are
working the way they are
there's another use case where we
heavily rely on metrics
and that is for actually data driven
development in Das so when we make
decisions about algorithms or
implementations in our system where we
suspect that there will be performance
issues we like to run a B test to
understand how does this affect a
variety of different workloads that we
see in the wild does it improve then
does it suddenly cause things to to
spike up clusters not finishing memory
blowing up all those kinds of things
and if you want to learn more about that
I will not tell you about this but
instead my colleague Guido Imperial will
do this later today at this talk um on
data driven design for the Das scheduler
now so much for metrics and with that
also for Telemetry data as we said like
Telemetry data is great if you have in
your system but we need a way to access
it
we've already seen that centralized
logging and centralized metrics
platforms can do this for us
but there are also a few tools we have
built into desk that allow us to
diagnose things directly
for example we've already seen the
dashboards and the visualization it has
this is quite useful in disk has a lot
of information in there we see the
progress the Clusters make and we see
this pew pew plot up in the middle that
basically tells us which worker is
talking to whom and a lot more things we
can track GPU memory
utilization whatever
these plots are catered at specific
things we want people to have an
understanding about in the system
so they're usually pretty useful but
once again since they're not in some
external system they're ephemeral if
you're not looking at them at the right
point in time or something interesting
is happening you're kind of out of luck
so
what we did to solve the part of this
pain is that we also added performance
report
and these things you can use as a
context manager they just wrap around
the work we want to track
and with that we take a subset of those
measurements we've seen before and
compile them into basically one HTML
page that people are able to then store
and share
like we see the task stream here
we see once again some metrics that we
can use
and interestingly we also have some
profiling
yeah now profiling we just saw the first
plot there this is the one thing you
probably won't get around if you really
want to dig into performance analysts of
your systems and of your workloads for
this in-dos we have a built-in profiler
at the slash profile endpoint
this is a statistical CPU profiler so
it's far from perfect
and but it's great because it's low
overhead so it's always on as soon as
you suspect something to be fishy about
performance you can just take a look at
this
it also Aggregates profiles across the
entire cluster or you can drill down
into individual workers depending on
what you want to look at
the two downsides are that is first of
all python only so
um
if you heavily rely on things that you
see bindings you won't see what's going
on in there
so if it's a heavy panels workload it's
basically just doing all Sub C or so
um
you don't really see much unfortunately
it also lacks a bit of a rich timeline
you get this flame graph which
Aggregates what happened over time and
tells you like how much time was taken
up by what but you don't see a
distribution of a time for that
if you want to take a look at something
like that there is also the more
in-depth profiling option to use the
dasc pi spy package this essentially
allows you to take the
great and famous Pi spy profiler and run
this on a Das cluster
requires some more work but it also goes
way deeper into
um
into the system you learn a lot more
from this
so with that
I've told you about most of the
important things that we haven't asked
time is all starting to run out let's
let's zoom out a bit what have you
learned today
first and foremost we've learned that in
observable system lets us ask why
something is happening
that's the main question we want to ask
and that's the question that helps us
answer
to do this logging and metrics are two
key pillars that we need
but also we need good diagnostic tools
that help us to refine this data that we
have collected somewhere and then
hopefully stored obscurity
to really gain insights and as a user to
be able to make make sense of those
um
we also learned dasc has a lot of
built-in logging metrics and diagnostic
tools
but if you really want to make use of
those and fully leverage them
in Das and in any distributed system you
want to use centralized and durable
collection of their Telemetry data
there's pretty much no way around this
this can get annoying this is something
where you can use a managed service like
call to help you with but um
yes this you want to have this if you
don't want to deal with um
well as it's aging into 100 different
machines
thanks
[Applause]
thank you Hendrick he was three minutes
early more questions yes more questions
who has a question
hello my name is Guinea I'm from
Alliance Technologies and uh I have a
question so how do I approach debugging
the Deadlocks caused by
a few tasks with fairly large footprint
being started
maybe at the same time
um
Deadlocks and ask uh give me this is
actually interesting we've spent
significant amount of time over the last
couple of months basically like last
year to not have any Deadlocks my main
question to you would be which version
are you on
have you upgraded recently I think
yeah in that case
um I would invite you to come over to a
booth later
um first of all my first guess would be
debug this by upgrading because there
has been a lot of work on this and like
at the moment there aren't really any
Deadlocks we're aware of if they are
still in there we definitely need to
talk
um but yeah like
there's also a tool for that that we
have we have basically cluster dump
which allows you to reproduce everything
that happened in the cluster so if
something basically tracking all the
state transitions of individual tasks um
that's very useful for those kinds of
things but also very heavy
um
but yeah let's let's talk
hello
Allianz Germany thanks for the wonderful
presentation I found it very
understandable very meaningful
um we do not use the system in fact this
is very much new for me but still
we use spark or Pi spark which is also
distributed computing engine and I was
wondering um how would you say does dusk
compared to spark or Pi spark and
especially with regards to what you have
been presenting here can you maybe give
any insights on this
um
I think there's like a few different
aspects of this first of all once again
my main question is what do you use Pi
spark for because that kind of frames
the question a bit
what kind of workloads do you run
so the main things that would
differentiate between uh Pi spark or
spark and dasc here is that
um dusk is more flexible and what it can
do so uh spark is
pretty good at data frame stuff because
it's built for that but task is more
General so um if you venture out of that
you'll see some benefits in terms of the
customizability of what kind of
workloads you can run in Das compared to
to Pi smart
the other one is that
task is first of all python only so you
kind of avoid the entire jvm stack and
it has very good Integrations into the
pi data ecosystem so
um
if you have something you've built in
pandas you can pretty much just take
that import something different which is
Dos data frames instead of pandas and
use that for pi spark you have to
rewrite it in this Pi Spar data frame
API
hi um I have another second part sorry
there was a second part of the question
which was observability
um where I think
both systems have useful observability
in there I'm not entirely aware of what
pi spark exactly offers
um
there for both systems yeah it's a pain
to set some of this up both systems have
managed service like data breaks or or
cloud in that sense that make this a lot
easier for you
um
I don't know if there's one that has
much better Telemetry or observability
than the other it really boils onto your
use case
sorry yes
okay I have two questions first of all
thank you for the nice talk
um first question is how long does tasks
store the metrics and logs
um
if you're talking about OSS standard
task
as long as whatever machine you want to
ask a question is alive or as long as
any worker or schedule is alive that's
the big thing or the big downside I
talked about so um if you don't use any
additional tooling to centrally collect
those logs or metrics as soon as you
shut down your cluster things are gone
or if your worker dies any information
from that worker is gone that's
that's a big problem but that's also
something you can't really solve in that
sense because by definition you need an
external system to set up okay and
that's the second question is it
possible to to send logs to open
Telemetry for example
um I haven't dealt with this myself but
yes it should absolutely be possible
like I mean there's different setups you
can do this one thing is you can just
by default that sends everything to to
standard alternate error you can just
add a more at a lower level just pick
this up and then send this over to open
Telemetry you could also then one way
I'd see is install something on the
workers that does this within the python
processes themselves for example in your
streaming Handler
yeah
okay great thank you
thank you for your questions and let's
thank Hendrick again for his
presentation
[Applause]